scènes de chaos devant le parlement
kirghiz et sa place à la toux théâtre
d'affrontements violents dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi entre la police et les
manifestants
le bilan fait état de plus de 120
personnes blessées et d'au moins un mort
à l'origine de ces échauffourées les
élections législatives de ce dimanche à
l'issue du scrutin seules quatre des
seize partis en lice ont remporté la
totalité des 120 sièges des partis
proches du président sauront de beijing
comme des résultats controversés sur
fond de crainte d'irrégularités à
l'origine de la révolte il ya tant de
choses qui ont été brûlés et cassé tant
de personnes ont été blessées c'est une
perte énorme
nous espérons que tout ira mieux quand
la tension baissera nous espérons que
tout ira mieux
nous prions pour qu'allah nous donne des
autorités juste de son côté le président
déplore la situation et tenter de calmer
le jeu
watteau mégane duster chers compatriotes
certaines forces politiques ont tenté de
s'emparer illégalement du pouvoir la
nuit dernière
elles ont utilisé les élections comme
prétexte et ont violemment perturbé
l'ordre public
privant les citoyens pacifiques de repos
j'ai proposé à la commission électorale
centrale de mener une enquête
approfondie sur les violations et si
nécessaire d'annuler les résultats du
vote
je demande aux dirigeants des partis
politiques de calmer leurs électeurs et
de les éloigner des lieux publics une
crise politique inquiétant alors que du
côté des observateurs louaient c'est
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe semble satisfait
du déroulement des élections les
élections législatives du 4 octobre se
sont déroulées dans le cadre d'une
législation améliorer les droits et
libertés fondamentaux ont été
globalement respectée
les allégations crédibles d'achat de
voix et d'abus de ressources
administratives
tous deux interdits par la loi ont été
les plus préoccupantes pour notre équipe
d'observateurs
un avis qui n'est pas partagé par les
manifestants qui ont libéré l'ex-chef
d'état almazbek atambaïev reconnu
coupable de corruption en juin est
condamné à 11 ans de prison
on regarde l'aggravation de la situation
la commission électorale a décidé
finalement d'annuler le résultat des
élections législatives